"Il était une fois,
dans la ville de ... "
"Foix ?
-Non, en Grèce,"
"dans la ville de Engraisse."
"Ca n'existe pas
la ville de Engraisse."
"Si, on peut l'imaginer."
"Une réunion, sur l'invention
du cheval de Troie."
"De foix?
-Ouais"
"Ah, voilà! Je le savais"
Messieurs,
je déclare ouverte
la 73eme réunion
pour choisir le truc de Troie.
Alors on fait quel animal?
Et pourquoi un animal?
-Ben c'est parce qu'on a validé ça,
la semaine dernière,
tétais pas là,
donc c'est un animal qu'on fait.
Ben non, un légume c'est bien aussi
par exemple.
Non, non, non.
-Si, si.
Une tomate.
Non.
C'est un fruit la tomate.
Ecoute, on a tranché la dernière fois,
un animal en bois,
c'est le mieux.
OK, je vois qu'on n'a pas besoin de moi,
je me casse.
Oh non, non mais allez, reviens,
on choisit l'animal ensemble!
je reviens si on fait...
Une tortue
-J'aime bien!
Une tortue c'est bien,
ça ressemble un peu à une tomate
mais en fruit.
Donc ça ferait
la tortue de Troie?
C'est pas terrible.
Ouais, c'est vrai.
-Non! C'est bien une tortue.
J'ai !
L'aigle de Troie.
Un aigle c'est tellement classe,
en plus si on agite bien les ailes
on peut voler.
Non.
-Si.
Si on agite vite.
Comme ça,
avec de l'élan.
Qui t'a dit ça?
Moi.
Sérieux, on peut pas.
Les oiseaux ils le font.
Les oiseaux ne sont pas en bois.
Et arrête!
Non mais un aigle?
Un aigle j'aime pas.
C'est trop genre «Hehe, regardez,
j'offre des aigles en bois
en cadeau, hehe!»
Ok, pas de soucis,
alors donne moi 3 animaux
et on choisit dedans.
Facile: le lapin, le cheval
et la mouche.
La mouche?
-La mouche!
Ok, donc toi en cadeau,
t'offres des mouches?
Ok, je retire la mouche.
Je sais, moi, moi! J'ai une idée!
Une girafe!
Non, faudrait construire des escaliers.
Bah je vais faire pipi.
Mais, c'est qui lui?
C'est le fils de l'autre là,
avec les trucs sur ...
On est obligé de le garder.
-Ok, bon.
Donc, Il nous reste le lapin
et le cheval.
J'ai fait pipi!
La mouche!
Ok, alors c'est parti
pour le cheval.
Il peut être couleur tomate?
-Non,
il sera couleur cheval.
-Oh, c'est raciste!
Pas du tout.
-Si, oh si, oh si si.
Et tu le sais, oh oui,
tu le sais en disant ça.
Tu dis «Ouhou, regardez moi,
je suis un raciste, hehe!».
La mouche !
Ok, adjugé pour
le cheval de Troie.
Le nom est super classe
et on pourra mettre plein de soldats dedans
et on pourra dire que c'est un cadeau.
Comme ça ils le mettront dans leur village.
Ils acceptent tout quand c'est gratuit
ces crevards de Troyens.
Et ouais, voilà,
ça c'était raciste.
Voilà!
Je vais partir, on se voit mardi?
-Oui!
Et en attendant,
crêpes pour tout le monde!
Youhou!
Sauf moi, je me casse,
j'en peux plus.
"Et c'est ainsi que débuta"
"la construction
du cheval de Troie."
"En tout cas
d'après des chaussettes."